[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
all right
now
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
my brother
foreign
[Music]
yeah bro
hold up
it's a my hero shirt
look at that
look to me you got a bunch of anime
shirts brother yeah I got a a Kaiser on
right now yeah I know you guys can hear
me we we live we live live
Mass
it's been a crazy week man
we we there's so much salt to navigate
through dirt it's it's unreal
not so much so much
you like my I got the
nice headphones man yeah and it's a nice
controller you got over there man
by the Xbox series oh yeah nice
this is kind of like because I just made
a video so this is literally how I how
like my videos are are set up for
you know we we got a lot of stuff going
on man we got a lot of stuff we got a
big show for you guys if if I say so
myself
yeah
so much to talk about right oh oh the
dude there isn't there isn't even a
little bit left man and okay I want to
be honest with you guys uh we most
likely
time stamps gonna be a little iffy today
okay
just a little iffy today
hey I'm on a podcast can you guys go
over there please thank you so as you
guys can see you know I got I got the
the star filled headset star field
controller I want to point out Microsoft
did not send us things we bought these
so
now controller looks pretty cool bro
it's it's it's nice man it really is
like what I like is like hold up let me
like
it's a nice little controller man yeah
it looks weird that looks pretty cool
bro
and look at that wasn't going to get one
but you guys are making me want to get
one because I have so many controllers
now I have like eight of them yeah so
hold up I'll show you all the controls I
have don't make fun of this next one but
it's a redfall controller
no hey red ball yeah we we will we will
move on and then I got this blue
controller
it's like the midnight blue one
this is the one I usually use is this
midnight blue one
oh okay yeah yeah and then I got like
the old standard controller
oh yeah man
oh classic yeah so yeah it's
we got a big show for you guys man you
know we're not gonna do what the
majority people do we're gonna wing it
you know because that's what the attic
show about we wean [__] around here
we don't do anything and I I want to
point out I know there's like a huge
flux of people that's coming in here
that you're it's crazy IOP grew like
almost 2 000 Subs in like 15 days that's
fire bro uh and I think you know shout
out to fratanga you know
you know how many people have used us
and to make fun of PlayStation Fanboys
especially King you know they got me
doing the back to back thing yeah back
yeah I mean we got a clip of that on uh
my boy Shawn he got you saying back to
back yeah you guys feel free to use me
man if you can get if you get them views
up by using me do it do it back to back
I want back-to-back stuff for you guys
man that's what I want
sorry
thank you guys for coming to the actual
we talked about the past present future
game I got my Coast with me Dirk rickety
man what's going on
nothing much man I'm feeling real good
man I had a little impossible not to
feel real good right now
that's at Us Xbox fans
we're feeling real actually you know
instead of Lord addict
there we go
that's what my name is for the day dirt
that's what my name is for the day
it's called Lord's back door back to
back all right so obviously
how many people obviously I'm assuming
the majority of the chat we got 210
people in the chat already
uh I'm sure you know a lot of you watch
the Xbox show man there's a lot of stuff
going on man you know uh we didn't have
a show last week you know I don't even
you know what's crazy I don't even
remember like a hundred percent of what
we talked about the last static show
yeah yeah we predicted yeah we didn't
even talk about the PlayStation showcase
it doesn't look like
like because I don't see that oh my God
we didn't talk about the PlayStation
showcase
before that you think no we did we did
the reaction that week
because it was the same day so look you
guys are gonna get a double dose of
goodness we're gonna talk about the
failure of PlayStation first half of the
show and then we were talking about the
fact that that Xbox took that failure
and they ran a football field man so
let's let's let's let's do the the cliff
notes of the PlayStation show we've been
gone for a minute guys we've been gone
for a minute first off I want to point
out was my dude put Jade up on that show
not once but twice
yo he I love it you know shout out to J
Dove for this for the sportsmanship man
how you okay look I'm sorry sir I don't
know about you
but if I if I sat through that
PlayStation showcase and I saw how
horrible that [__] was when it came to
the Xbox showcase man I got I got I got
a doctor's appointment
letters no way you would have talked me
into coming there for round two
yeah man I mean kudos to him for showing
up because you know all Xbox had to do
with show a couple games and and it
would have been better than PlayStation
showcase but he showed up yeah so it is
what it is you know I know a lot of Xbox
people including yourself you guys ain't
the biggest J Duff fan but he came in
there man he he got he got a he got
abused
it's crazy man the the amount of people
that clipped him was absolutely
insane and I love it I love it because
it because to me it's like you know Jada
you choose this Persona on Twitter you
choose to go in there with that smoke
you about to get this smoke
but you know I appreciate everyone
coming through the chat you know we're
gonna talk about the PlayStation thing
so obviously we saw how bad the
PlayStation showcase was it wasn't even
it was bad as in terms of showcase it
was bad because we expected more from
these this company at this point so you
know what what I wanted to hear from you
is
now that we know what we know
do you think that
oh gosh okay my bad guys now that we
know what we know do you think that play
Xbox did
what they what they were supposed to
absolutely man they they gave us updates
on existing games that has been
announced they showed some new IPS with
an Exiles game
um Clockwork Revolution also uh South to
Midnight Man listen they put on a damn
good show bro had a couple of good
multi-place in there some great games
Game Pass announcements Xbox did that
thing and they did what they supposed to
do especially after that awful
PlayStation show yeah I think I think
the PlayStation made it even worse for
the man like they they should have just
not had a show like that I'm gonna be
honest with you they should have just
had a direct and show things maybe there
was some kind of marketing agreement
where it had to be a showcase
or something like that to some of this
stuff let me tell you something I was
nervous right as an Xbox guy tell me
tell me the console war stuff tell me
when when that time was was counting
down uh like when it was like the five
minutes lower tell me you weren't like
please Xbox don't mess up
bro let me tell you something um first
let me go to PlayStation for a second
like I said I was nervous as a guy that
does contour stuff
on my YouTube channel I was like you
know what I'm looking I'm like
damn they ain't [__] they ain't they
ain't had a show in two years this show
about to be fire
and I'm watching I'm like damn this is
this is dog [__] and I'm watching now
watching damn it so I said okay like
maybe like 2021 they're gonna have an
average show until the last 10 minutes
like 2021 showcase
and I'm looking I'm like whoa they said
it's an hour we're out of hour right now
and all they showing is Spider-Man I
said oh this show was terrible so with
Xbox show
the first couple of games I'm like oh
they already beat PlayStation I'm sorry
they already beat that show
first couple of games that we know uh
you know it's only one
complain I had about Xbox so that was
one
um and well the Xbox show was dope man I
get them full credit
you know because after last year's shows
it was you know like like last year's
show was kind of average because of the
whole 12-month thing and
they redeemed themselves sir
to this uh this this this showcase man
let's get into the Showcase I have a lot
and what I like about this two Dart is
we're coming off of like a couple days
from the Showcase because I do feel like
there's a lot of like initial takes and
now you know since the Showcase was
three days ago we have a lot of like
initial reactions and we can really
break stuff down because stuff has sat
with us for a little bit you know I
don't want to go into like overall games
I don't want to go into what your rating
is or anything I just want to know
exactly what your expectations were
going into the Showcase and some things
maybe they lived up to and some things
because obviously it wasn't a perfect
show but it was a really good show so I
want to know what your expectations were
and what is something that they maybe
surpassed your expectations in terms of
what was there what was something that
didn't hold up to your expectations
well I'm gonna say this my expectations
was for Xbox you know like I said for
them to update us on some some
previously announced games
to announce some new IPS
um to to show show certain things now
I'm gonna tell you what exceeded my
expectations
first off for them to start off the show
with Fable and for it to look like that
and it's not CGI right for it to look
that great in-game footage
blew me away
and when people start to question
because this has happened a few times
when when people start to question
whether this game is CGI or not
I love it there's a few gangsters that
this has happened before remember Forza
Horizon five there were guys saying
that's not gameplay but it was gameplay
when they were showing like the
mountains then they went to the cars
driving people that's not gameplay yes
it was gameplay same thing with Halo
Blade 2 back in 2021 you know like
there's some some gameplay mixed with
some cinematics but but people said it
was CGI no it wasn't same thing with
Fable they said in engine footage at the
bottom of the screen
some people flat out call Microsoft
Liars say y'all lying
that's playground games like that right
they have a habit of making very
attractive looking games
yeah yeah so people call them flat out
liars and I'm like wow
um then if you watch that Phil Spencer
interview with John bomb and and the guy
I can't remember his name but he said
yeah Fable I don't know like y'all they
show no gameplay and Phil said what
makes you think that wasn't gameplay
what makes you think that wasn't
gameplay because it looks that good man
so
um
that was some great things at that show
like I said the only disappointment I
have had was um no hellblade to Combat
gameplay I wanted to see more it's a
little spooky looked a little spooky
yeah yeah I mean I mean I I trust Ninja
Theory I trust them
um so but like we'll see what happened
but I was uh that was a little
disappointment
but that's about it man all right let me
get these Super Chat Circle we got a two
dollar switch out from flame you know
what's funny flame I saw um I saw
someone making a video that had your
name that like your face on it I think
it was I think it was Neo spark it was
funny
uh
showcase topics back-to-back attic let's
go appreciate the support man follow us
which are from Buck I'm a Halo I'm a
Halo gears Doom Xbox fan basically love
violence and combat I was shocked that
starfield's combat looks so good that
made the show fire we're gonna get into
Starfield we're gonna really break down
starfoot normally I try to get us out of
here like an hour 20 30. this might be a
two I ain't gonna lie there's a lot to
go over I'm gonna try to get us out of
here an hour and a half though Spartan
ghost 17 with two uh Super Chat I was
very disappointed by a vowed show was an
8.5 out of 10.
um we'll get into a vow too uh I have I
I I'm a little bit with you on that spot
but not necessarily the way you guys
think all right so let's get in a little
bit you know I I do want to go ahead and
just get my opinions on that I felt like
they exceeded my expectations because I
think I'm gonna be real with you I'm one
of this expecting something good but
expecting them to mess up at the same
time so but you know you know when I
knew
you know what I knew we had the promised
land we we hit the Home Run we was going
above and beyond
is when I saw that Fable come out
from the start
and then they and then they followed and
Fable up with what
compulsions game like yeah it's just
like I I do think in the middle was a
little bit
is like the pacing not necessarily the
pacing uh just some of the games that
really appease to me you know I do want
to go into that uh in terms of like
games as a service stuff like that but
what I want to talk about is I want to
talk about
the pacing of this show I feel like the
pacing was well done look people get
this like misconstrued thing that pacing
is just games that you don't care no
that's still good pacing maybe you don't
care about the content that that's been
said but
you can have good pacing and still show
bad games but I I feel like they really
went above and beyond to get not only
indie games and double A games but
Indian double A games that looked
appealing because people don't mind
seeing Indie Games in double A games
something like the 33 games that looked
appealing that looked like something I
would try out even the game with the
claiming thing
did you see that I think it was uh
someone posted on Twitter that said
PlayStation fed's gonna love that
climbing game
it's just like
felt like they did it man the the the
way that they went up they presented
this the biggest critique I could give
them right now is when they show clock
tower uh Revolution I don't know if it
was Clock Tower or not the biggest CR
criticize I can give is Phil should came
out before that and said did his outro
and then go into that game and then go
into the Starfield because I felt like
we're sitting here like building
anticipation waiting for that just one
that last that last moment thing and
then he does the last moment thinking
goes into Starfield and I felt like you
could have did better there you know
obviously hellblade should have had
combat you know this has been shown not
once not twice but I'm pretty sure this
is the third time that we've seen
hellblade
and she hasn't pulled out her sword one
time
I mean I think she threw some Spears but
that's besides the fact you know
Microsoft I know you watch this channel
I don't know if you watched the attic
show I would assume that some of you do
we need to see combat and I think the
question I have to you uh you know
regarding the Showcase is do you think
that these showcase is going to be a
little bit different in how we have
interpretated them all this time because
of the Xbox directs because if you think
about it it's easy for them to come out
here and show yo we're going to show you
this trailer to get you more hyped for
for hellblade which I think they could
have did a little bit better than what
we got but then
in three or four months we're going to
do a direct that focuses on all of the
combat for for help late what's your
opinion on that I think I think that's
something that all of the big companies
are going to do moving forward
especially you know the big three
they'll show game off
um they'll show certain things about the
game but they might hold back specific
things that they want to like have a
deep have a deep dive into right
um
like this this year with Starfield they
had that deep dive into it you know um
excuse me so I do believe they you know
stuff like that might happen on the big
big game that's being closer to being
released because of these directs and
you know stuff like that yeah that's
definitely possible for it to happen so
you know we like we feel a certain kind
of way about it
I'm sure the combat will be fine we're
anxious to see not like because it's
like this we know the game is beautiful
we know the mocap is top of the line Top
Notch motion capture we know all that
the only thing that we really want to
see at this point is combat and not the
I believe Ninja Theory knows that Xbox
knows that so they might do a direct
next January because Matt booty did hint
at having another developer's direct
early next year
this that's the 2024 game that will most
likely be there so they're going to show
it but you know it's about us being
patient but but like you said they've
shown it three times
but we know the game is beautiful
do you think it would have been better
if they just kept hellblade off for this
docket entirely
you know maybe make a statement before
the show that says look we got something
for hellblade in the future but you know
right now we want to focus on the games
that you haven't seen because to me I
feel like
the biggest criticism for this game is
the combat if they didn't show the
combat to me
it would have been better for them to
just keep this off the docket if they
weren't going to show the combat then
just show us another CGI that really
didn't show us anything like if you
really look at it and you look at the
past couple shows that we've seen on
hellblade nothing has been answered we
know exactly as much as we knew a few
years ago because all they keep showing
is this game looks good guess what Xbox
I knew this game was going to look good
there was no denying if this game was
going to look good or not good and to me
if that if you weren't going to be able
to show the consumer and you know us
what we want to see then you should have
just held hellblade off the show
until you were ready for the direct I
disagree don't hold it off the show you
know why because there was already some
Buzz that was going to release this year
um let people know you know it's not
going to release Sushi areas next year
um because I don't really see another
opportunity like maybe what games come
or or you know uh the the vgas to to let
people know that it's dropping next year
if XBox would have went quiet about
tailblade release window people would
have complained about that also you're
right so go ahead
show the game people gonna
be upset about the lack of combat they
know that but now we know the game is
coming next year that's that's a
positive I feel you on that I feel you
on that but to me maybe do a different
trailer because like I feel like this is
the worst showing we've seen of
hellblade like it's literally like all
it told us is she's she's crazy we knew
that
like we didn't need to see this like
bring something else
to the table we know that she's got
mental issues it's the whole point of
these games is to ex is to go through
her mental issues with her and to me
maybe you should have showed a different
form of story that that's what I'm
saying you know I don't know what they
could have done but to me there there
there was a way that they could have
made this work we got two dollars for
each other from free R Kelly show was
really bad stop the cap man you just in
here because King isn't here to check
you free R Kelly When you on my channel
boy yeah free R Kelly we we didn't let
you out like you know IOP gave you that
money so you could see you can actually
experience the library
the the wreck you know we gave you a
little bit on your books you can buy
some ramen noodles not for you to come
in here and use all of your your wreck
time on and come on this podcast and
talk that smack you know you should have
took that two you know how are you going
to Super Chat the money we sent you to
buy ramen noodles back to us
five dollar Super Chat from gaming Forte
I trusted you there too but it seems
like they dunking the combat put your uh
put your uh it's on the table and wow us
I agree but I do think to a point it's
not that they're ducking the combat I
think they're going to save that for the
last thing when they show the actual
release date for the game
yeah I mean I mean a little bro they
I mean this is is obviously their their
decision to show it when they're ready I
mean that's all we can do
yeah let's wait until they show gotta
find Us return
txh1138 ID software help Bethesda with
gun Combat on Starfield it looks much
better since last year glad to see other
Studios support each other we're going
to get into that you know uh I do want
to like move on with this is anything
else you want to talk about just the
overall showcase real quick you know
Jess that was a good show you know like
no show is perfect of course but I
thought they did pretty good with it
um and and I think they um if you if you
watch feels Phil Spencer's body language
at that giant they were confident they
were calling oh my God it was so
confident feels happy if you saw if you
compare Field Spencer with the kind of
funny interview to the Giant Bomb
interview two different people yeah two
different people the kind of funny
interview he was like oh man he like you
want to smack somebody you know but this
one he was happy smiling because he's
hearing this positive feedback
he sees that people saying the show was
great Starfield was great you know
who lost the Xbox these these new IPS
look great Clockwork Revolution looks
phenomenal stuff like that so he so yeah
he was definitely happy bro and
confident like you said confident yeah
so I mean when it comes down to it you
know two dollar Super Chat from uh
Spartan ghost one seven he says
hellblade was was showing the writing
quality tone I feel you on that but I I
think a lot of people they don't want to
see that you know we've seen that
multiple times at this point the only
thing people really realistically want
to see from the title hellblazers they
want to see the combat so let's let's
move on to
a vow you know we're going to get this
30 seconds
for the time stamp police
or the time stat Mafia I keep forgetting
what you guys okay about
how'd you feel about a vowel
I don't look fine um I don't know maybe
some people feel the graphics wasn't
good enough
um I'm sorry we play obsidian games I
mean their graph is never absolutely
amazing I love Auto worlds even high
average Graphics but I thought it looked
fine man it's uh it was kind of like
um I don't know what people was
expecting I wish you you know let me
know what you I mean because you said
that you were kind of disappointed also
I would like to know why you were
disappointed it's not that I was
disappointed I do feel like the tone
that they put out for
for a vowed and the
in the initial launch trailer made it
seem like it was going to be more of a
realistic art approach you know uh I'll
go ahead and bring up the original
Starfield trailer so we can go over it
together but yeah not Starfield a vowed
yeah you know it's funny because I saw
people saying about it has got a
downgrade I'm like what downgrade I
don't think it's got a downgrade I don't
think well the first Trader was CGI but
but I feel like
to a point you're right 100 you're right
on that but I would expect them to give
us some form of a realistic approach on
what it's going to look like in the
overall aspect of things even in a CGI
do you get what I'm saying
so you saying this CGI
um showed a darker tone a more realistic
tone you're saying yeah so uh what I'm
gonna do is uh
let me bring this over here
I'm a goal we're gonna watch the trailer
live let me give you the link uh dirt so
you can watch it with us
on my phone okay so we're gonna watch it
live I'm gonna start it now
all right so as you can see like I'm
pausing it right now at seven seconds
like this world obviously Cog wants to
go with the he thinks there's just more
colorful biomes and I can fill them to a
degree because you're not really seeing
a lot of color here it makes it looks
like just War
have always known but like what I'm
sitting here looking at this I'm not
thinking it's gonna have color for like
like right here very dark textures
there's not really a lot of color on
here and I'm not saying what they did
was right what they did was wrong what
I'm saying is they kind of gave us this
like Skyrim approach where the graphics
gonna look more Skyrim like like if you
look here you don't see no color nothing
it to me if you're comparing this
trailer and I don't see GI but to a
point you got to keep our expectations
realistic on CGI if they if they showed
this type of trailer and it looked like
sea thieves people would be getting
upset do you know what I'm saying like
like it doesn't matter even though it's
just CGI there is to a point where
you're looking at this game and you kind
of expect what the tone of the game is
going to look even on CGI
like see I'm looking here I I still
don't see like these colorful biomes
anywhere like let's pause right before
we hear the skeleton
like this skeleton looks way more
detailed like once again it is CGI I'm
not arguing with that but it's just like
and then let's go down here in the
bottom
you know this is like a cavern of some
sort
these guys but it might be some like be
some caverns in the game we just don't
know yet I mean I know and I'm not
saying that like we're not gonna see
stuff like this but I'm saying like this
this game looks more dark toned than
what we got like just when I pause at 53
seconds and you see you know him using
that spell like this Cavern this fire
there's no you know it could be strictly
just we're not seeing the areas that's
in this game that they showed in this
trailer and that could definitely be the
case like I I'm not gonna lie on that
that could that could definitely be the
case let me exit out of these now let me
say this let's watch the new one
okay because I would say they show
skeletons they show spells they I mean
they
it's hard to say see when I when I look
at this like this
doesn't look as like
like
was that
yo tell me this don't look like the
Fallout New Vegas uh in the new one for
11 seconds in it looks like the Fallout
uh New Vegas
well I mean I mean well that would make
sense though they may follow New Vegas
yeah it is funny it is funny
so like I'm I'm looking at this and like
even when you like go to this part you
know I get it this could just be
strictly
this could be just them showing
different areas in the game and I'm not
gonna say that
a hundred percent this isn't a bad thing
to me all right let me point that out I
was just disappointed a little bit
because I expected a more
darker art style than I got in the outer
worlds does that make sense like I'm not
I'm not hating on the game I'm still mad
excited about it but I was
a lot more excited than I was when I
first started watching this thank you
very much
like and it literally like when you
pause here this does look a little bit
more like that was in that trailer you
know what I'm saying like at 50 seconds
in the new trailer
so but I think the culprit of this like
when you look at here like I'm at 55
seconds like I'm looking at the world
like it doesn't
I feel like there's textures like the
textures don't look the greatest on here
like when I'm sitting here pausing it
like there's just not a lot of detail on
this on the world down there it's like a
lot of colorful stuff
like obviously this game still has
plenty of time to come out I don't want
to like give a definitive thing and I'm
not even going to say it's been
downgraded
you know but when you look at like I
when I got like you look at here
I think the problem is we just didn't
see biomes like this in the original
trailer
no original trailer was one minute and
22 seconds yeah I know but then like I
feel like this this disease stuff
doesn't really look the greatest
like it kind of looks like the disease
that you would see in grounded like on
the real like
I just I was disappointed a little bit
because I expected a little bit more
detail in these games in this game it
now it's not saying that this game is
going to be amazing there's a good
chance that this game's amazing it's
just to me
I still expect a 90 Plus on a valve 100
percent
but I would wish I would have got a
little bit more of like a realistic
approach does that make sense
listen brother this is how you feel I
can't tell you how to feel I mean in my
opinion are you being a little nitpicky
absolutely but it's your opinion
um
I don't know I mean it's it's hard to
um compare real gameplay to CGI and I'm
not I'm not like debating on whether or
not the game should have looked this or
the game should have looked at uh what I
will say is what I got it's it's kind of
like how I felt about the Spider-Man
thing you know people say the downgrade
on Spider-Man uh with the puddle game
you know the thing that Kofi and kids
move started so when you look at well
mainly Kofi but you look at puddle gate
they said that there was a lot of other
put other places in the game that look
better than that area
but if you took what that picture had
and you applied it to the rest of the
game
it was disappointing
you know what I'm saying
so it's like
oh my God let me get these super chats
they coming at me they come out you know
what I got time today okay I got time
today
I I don't know if I missed this super
chat before hold up let me see which one
people really nitpick everything Xbox
does uh
Okay no Okay yeah so we got two dollar
Super Chat from Dan Lorenzo people
really nitpick everything Xbox says no I
nitpick everything RPGs do okay that's
what I nitpick and I'm not gonna like
come at you for that that's how you feel
that's fine if you feel like I'm
nitpicking then I'm nitpicking to you uh
Jazz 82 with the 10 secret people say
the Xbox show was bad and not being real
with themselves nor are the guys
covering it being real I listen to IOP
and wbg and others for that reason to
lie to yourself don't lie to me
was bad no one's saying the show was bad
no no I don't think he was talking about
you he's talking about you know some
people Spartan uh ghost 17 yep it's a
change in art Direction and tone
cyberpunk followed the exact same tone
from reveal but without even has a
different style logo and tone that's all
I'm saying I'm like look
is it gonna stop the game from being
amazing probably not but I did expect a
little bit more of a realistic approach
when it comes to the art style I'm not
saying this looks card like cartoony or
anything like that but there's a lot
more vibrant colors in this than I
initially anticipated
five dollar super trap from uh Kayla
Walker during the Xbox 2 podcast just
said that
um they changed the direction for a
valid about two years ago so after the
trailer and that could easily be what
happened I'm not really uh debate I
don't know okay let me get this one find
out super chat from 80s20 zero attic
stop bro you sound ridiculous that
that's fine you could say I sound
ridiculous and I probably do sound
ridiculous to a lot of you guys but I
played the outer worlds too I played the
pillars of Eternity games I played
Skyrim I played Fallout New Vegas I
played Fallout 3 I played Fallout 4. I
actually play these games okay I love
the worlds that obsidian and Bethesda
make and you know I I can't say that my
my
my my height for a vow didn't go down a
little bit when I saw
it looked like a different visualization
that I pictured in my head now sure
sure maybe
I put too much of what I wanted off of
what I seen in that CGI into existence
and expected that but to me it looked
different than I envisioned and I have
every right to fill let down you know I
love the outer worlds too when homegirl
said in the extended showcase that you
know I feel like
this isn't gonna be like the sky or it's
gonna be more like the outer worlds
where you know there's there's Hub
worlds and you go to I want that I don't
care about that open World stuff
I guarantee you right now I'm still 100
on this about speed
but at the same time I can't I cannot
say that I wasn't disappointed with what
I saw not necessarily gameplay not
necessarily how they were talking just
the visualization that I felt the
graphics looked compared to what I got
when they're actually in gameplay
okay so you're saying this this is just
a you you issue you expected something
different I did it's like I said but see
here's the thing like I can't say a
hundred percent that they didn't give me
these expectations you know what I'm
saying like because when you look at
that I get it it's a CGI
but generally they give you the tone of
the art style they're going with with
CGI you don't see stuff like Jedi
Survivor let's say they show you that
and then you get the game and it looks
like sea thieves like we'd be a little
upset and I'm not saying that's what
they did here I'm just giving you like a
an example of if they change things
around like that you know they they seem
like this game was going to be very dark
tone when they originally announced it
but then when we actually see in the
gameplay it looks more like the co the
type of you know color tone that the
outer worlds has and that's not a bad
thing I love the outer worlds I think
the outer words is an amazing game it's
just to me personally I was a little
disappointed when I saw what I
visualized a vow to look like in my head
it's not that it was a drastic
difference but the tone difference was
that it was it was different that don't
okay so I understand you saying the the
tone um because they didn't really show
any characters in The CGI besides a
skeleton and you know they show the
skeleton and the green dude
right not well and I felt like this well
I'm talking about the CGI trailer all
they show was some arrows oh yeah and
some skeletons and then they showed a
spell they show the spell and they show
some skeletons so
um
I see what you're saying kind of
but this is this is you like this is how
you were feeling so I can't tell you how
you should feel
the tone um is is a little different but
is it it's hard to say this the the
entire game is going to be like this
though you know what I'm saying is it
gonna like change
how I feel about the game overall in the
grand scheme and things probably not uh
because regardless what it is out of
Worlds was an amazing game I love that
damn game and the idleworlds 2 is going
to be more of the outer words that I'm a
hundred percent okay with that but I
always envisioned when I played a vow I
would get more of a Skyrim type fill
where you know you walk around the world
it kind of feels like a you know a
darker kind of tone you know you get
that dark music that's what I expected
now but how do you know it's only like a
two minute trailer though I feel you and
I'm not those things but I'm just
telling you my what I saw like obviously
yeah obviously this could be different
we literally could be seeing just
different biomes like call things and
that could very well be it but from what
I was saw what I saw from that CGI it
felt like it was two different art
styles that they collided and met in the
mid little in the end
okay
no brought me you know I you know I I
thought the game looked fine I thought
it was good I can't wait to play it but
you know oh I can't wait to play it
either you know
I just isn't it fun homestays I'm like
isn't it funny
when these PlayStation Fanboys when
when Jess Gordon said something they
agree with they they all of a sudden
believe everything he uh says right all
of a sudden Knicks like believes
everything just Gordon says no
get out of here man you know how that
stuff goes it's just when it comes down
to it man you know
because you got a PlayStation podcast to
go to Joey Crockett said addict is
supposed to be a pillars Universe I feel
you on that and I played a little bit of
pillars I really need to go back and
like actually play the pillars the
reason I'm so excited about a valid even
with the the little bit uh of change in
tone that I think has been changed is
pillars universe is lit it's awesome I
think people are gonna love the pillows
Universe the fact that a vowel is going
to be that like the gods and pillars of
Eternity
uh they're they're literally only in
existence because they were conjured
like
it's gonna be good I think you guys are
gonna like it I really think you guys
are gonna like it I don't I still have
100 faith in obsidian 100 faith in
obsidian if they felt the need to you
know maybe tone back the the art style a
little bit I have every faith that they
have a reason they did that you know
what I'm saying
el Nina 30 FPS about better not be 30
FPS
all right
so you you want to keep going back and
forth beyond the fact because I got it
let's go man all right it's cool man
it's cool we can move on
so let's talk about fable
so uh you know clearly
everyone here knows I'm a huge faithful
person
and I people were messaging me like
crazy during the event talking about
fable
and what I thought about it so I'm Gonna
Save my my stuff for a minute because I
want I want to I want to get your
opinion first Dirk because you you were
coming in there pretty much like open to
the Fable franchise because you haven't
really played it to a huge degree
correct I finished part two
I played a little bit of part three I
never well I I played a little bit of
part one also so I didn't really finish
all of the games but I played I did
finish part two though
okay so what was your opinion on on
Fable
look man um
I I gotta be honest when they showed the
trailer you know when they show
playground games I was like oh snap here
it is fellas and when they show the game
I said whoa and when you saw it said
in-game footage not in engine it said
end game footage and if you really pay
attention you can tell some parts were
gameplay
um man I was really very impressed first
off with the graphics
then it's obviously they're going with
some type of Jack and the Beanstalk
um storyline or or whatever and they're
still keeping that Fable comedy you know
you saw the chick kick the chicken and
somebody called her a wanker and she
turned around like what you know
it looks great man
um some of the stuff I'm hearing
about the trailer they're saying the
girl is ugly uh that's that's how Fable
is though like Fable has that look I
agree that that happens to a degree in
the industry but it's just like that's
the world of fable that yeah and if
anything I think they were just showing
you like the diverse types of characters
you can make in the game with the
character development yeah yeah man it's
just I mean it's just so much
um so so people calling Xbox and
playground games Liars they're saying
they're flat out line you are lying that
is not in-game footage um so we'll see
what happens with that
but I was fairly impressed with what
Fable what what playground game show the
Fable man um I I wasn't expecting it to
look that good at it
now we know Forza Horizon looks great
but but those are racing games right
um so when you heard they're using the
forza engine for this game he was okay
how are they gonna do that and but I
wasn't expecting it to look that great I
I know Matt Moody last year said they
were they really wanted to show
something and playground games was like
not yet that booty was like yeah they're
really they're they're really doing some
great stuff over their playground
bro I wasn't expecting it to look like
that
it looks incredible
all right so how comes the Fable is
I thought this was a good showing a
fable I thought this was a good middle
ground I would have preferred a little
bit more gameplay but I understand why
you know they can't they can't show us
everything you know this game's still
gonna take some time to come out I
expect like early 2025 that's when I
would expect this game to come out
and I'm looking at the trailer and I'm
sitting there and I'm just hyped man you
know they showed us a good amount that
um that had me understand where the game
was going in the direction the game was
going but I never felt like they needed
to show me more for the most part like I
said I could have used more gameplay uh
I would have preferred a little bit more
raw gameplay than edited gameplay and
that that's that's my criticism I think
I could have uh I could I would have
wanted that too but when I'm looking at
this and I'm looking at the way that the
character models look especially when
she hit that dude with the fireball you
know the fact that they pretty much
officially announced that there's some
form of giants in the game you know I
don't know if the individual that was in
there was the only Giant in the game I
don't know but I I don't know I think he
was a boss I really do think he was a
boss because you notice at the end of
the trailer she was glasses on his
glasses yeah yeah
so I'm kind of curious to see the only
giant of the game is there more yeah
that's a good question it just like I
like things like that I like that the
fact that it really does feel like they
are
opening
Fable to a different audience I've
always said here and I've said here for
a long time and you remember
dirt I said Xbox
needs to try to incorporate more people
to come to
the Fable franchise without abandoning
what makes Fable now when I'm sitting
there looking at this I saw
sprinkles of the British humor but if
you notice it didn't feel too much what
I saw in that trailer you know they they
had some good funny stuff but I feel
like there's a difference between forced
humor and just regular humor and I felt
like a lot of fable was forced you know
when I talk to people about what makes
Fable the majority of them don't say
that British humor they say I love the
way the world evolved I love the way you
know your your choices has a constant
consequences and effects you know the
fact that there's certain things you can
do that you're not gonna really
get a whole lot of that to later on in
the game there's multiple things like
that that's what I've been that's what I
see when people
say about favor now look does the
British humor help it yes
but what I saw on there is saw I saw
that British humor but I didn't saw no
farting stuff and I feel like these are
big
big mechanics of fable like the fart
systems and stuff like that I didn't see
that
I saw natural
humor that you could that you could pick
up in multiple different ways and it
didn't feel forced obviously the game
could be different but
I think Fable is gonna dial back the the
comedy that's been in the games I really
do
i i i because the way I saw it it looked
like it was there but it didn't look in
huge in huge waves what do you think
yeah
um it's possible that they're gonna
dollar back but at the end of the day I
didn't come on just a trailer
I mean but I mean we got it we gotta
dissect it how we see it you know what
I'm saying yeah but I mean I think this
is so much you can see in the two-minute
trailer uh of a game that will probably
be 20 to 30 hours long
um I feel you but that that trailer felt
more of a serious
like kind of world that I seen in any of
the other Fables
you know that like I said it's possible
it will be a more serious tone you know
you saw you know the werewolf uh I don't
know but the the giant they say he's a
British comedian
um
I never heard them because you know
obviously I'm an American but they say
he's a he's a British comedian so that's
that's something um you know that's
something I'm not saying that I could
put the British humor in it I'm saying
instead of putting because I felt like
there was always a balance with the
British humor and the type of gameplay
mechanics they have and I felt like it
was around the middle but what I saw in
here it felt like it's gonna lead more
towards an engaging world you know uh
what we're going to be doing in the
world the combat we're going to be doing
to the world and then there's going to
be there's still going to be British
humor but it's not going to be thrown in
your face
yeah I mean I mean that's definitely
possible maybe playground wants to add
some some humor but they might take a
more serious tone I mean who knows at
this point um I'm fine with either way
um you know there are some so I mean
like you say there's some humor I
understand what you're saying there's
humor in it but
you say you didn't hear any farting or
no no but these are huge things that's
in Fable like the the expression emote
that's in Fable two and three like the
people in this chat I I see homeboy that
made the five dollar super trap Adidas
20-0 he said addict listen and listen
good you sound crazy two minutes of
gameplay not 40 hours I'm out I can't
take it no more I appreciate you know
you you supporting the show man but I
could give my opinion without feeling
like I'm gonna be bullied no one in the
chat gonna bully me okay no one in the
chat gonna bully me
I look at something like this I'm still
excited like it's crazy I can't give any
form of even mild criticism without
people in the chat on my ass
okay two entrepreneur from El Nina I
agree with addict there we go man some
people sound like they they with me I'm
not saying it looks bad it's comedy
sketch
you know what there's a difference
between a comedy that's forced and a
comedy that is thrown in your face
go play Fable one two and three they
throw it in your face 24 7. when you
look at that trailer a lot of the comedy
stuff was just stuff that would
naturally happen when you're playing the
game
okay let me say this
do you think playground Games main focus
what do you think their focus was with
this two minute trailer do you think it
was to show the humor show the graphics
show the gameplay or show it was all a
little bit of everything right it was
awesome right so my point is
they couldn't put everything in this too
many trailers so I mean but look you
might be right they might take a more
serious tone with the game we just don't
know yet and I think it's too early to
to know because this game probably won't
come out to 2025. I still two more years
of development Maybe
what what like you won they don't have
in the game yet like who knows I'm just
trying to look at it at a different way
like it's a trailer
I think we're we're dissecting the
trailer
but at the same time we're expecting too
much out of a two-minute trailer and I'm
not disagreeing with you on that
but what I that's how that's all I know
how to do my dude
I see a trailer I'm a dissect the [__]
out of that okay like look it's just
some criticism not never even
necessarily it's just stuff I'm picking
up on you know when I when I see stuff
like that and I see what's going on and
I see that they did they they chose to
highlight the giant they chose to
highlight the humor of the Giants saying
they chose to highlight the the little
fighting they did the kicking the the
the the the the chicken they didn't
choose the high to highlight like crazy
expressions or all the other stuff that
you could do and that's that's what I'm
saying I'm saying that when it comes to
stuff like that it felt like that was
toned down
yeah um I think they did stuff with the
chicken like like kicking the chicken
just because that's something that
that's known
from the Fable franchise so they wanted
to give a
Ode to favorable like hey look we still
think they called you they called you
the kicking Chaser too so you know the
Chicken Chaser it's like look
I'm not saying that you guys are wrong
or right I'm just giving you my opinion
what's the point like you know what's
crazy the chat wants to come in here and
they want me to say the [__] they
thinking
what's the point of you being here
watching if I go say exactly what you
guys think
that ain't gonna happen yo they they
showed a great trailer of fable
a great trailer
so why you guys on my ass it's not like
I'm saying it's gonna be bad I didn't
say nothing like that if anything I've
done nothing but promote this damn game
I love what I saw
excuse me for having a mind of my own
and thinking differently
go on dirt
no that's about it
uh you know to tell you I guess you know
what I think what the chat
um
I feel with what they're upset because
well I think what they're saying is we
all said Xbox is a good uh no they had a
great show and we're talking about
certain things we're critiquing certain
things
um but I think some of the things that
they feel you're critiquing
is unnecessary like like it's not me
critiquing it's just me saying what I
noticed in the trailer I noticed they
spent more time on talking about like
the the laughing when the chick was
walking by or you know the giant talking
about the whether or not heroes are
around like they they didn't do all of
that to me
you know what
I get it I get it games was a service
you know the chat has definitely
triggered me they ain't gonna be no
denying that uh it is what it is you
know what guys you win today you win
today Fable needs to be exactly what
Fable one two and three was there's a
reason Fable one two and three wasn't
massive massive successes excuse me for
wanting my fable franchise to be like
the next big thing out there excuse me
for not wanting Fable to come out there
and do one damn game and never be seen
again excuse me I just saw something a
small PP I believe I said his name
properly he just said something that I
think we really need to pay attention to
he said at the end of the day this is
the lion's head Fable it is playground's
Fable I think that's fair and like we
should always remember that
but when I bring up stuff they could
potentially change from Lion head's
Fable they are my ass to the chat
so it it it's it's funny man it's funny
I see you guys it's funny
let's move on from Fable before I have
an aneurysm
all right all right so we're going we're
going to talk about
what's this compulsion game what's that
game called
South to midnight South to midnight let
me change the uh
the thing
South to midnight
all right tell me what you thought about
this because I didn't take nothing
really much about this game no well oh
like no they didn't show much of it
um I believe this was I I believe this
is compulsion way of showing you this is
what we're working on stop the tone of
the game this is what we're working on
stop tagging us and [__] yeah first I
always say I love the art style I love
it um spots South man New Orleans
I never been in New Orleans but um I you
know I used to listen to a bunch of
rappers from New Orleans so I used to
think I I knew New Orleans but obviously
I don't
um it looks very interesting man it
looks very interesting um like I said we
there's not much we can talk about it
but I love the art style and they said I
was in engine
that uh what is it uh like what do you
call that our our style that seems to I
don't know like it hasn't you know like
the miles of Morales movies you kind of
see that similar art style
I think it that looked great um but you
know there's not much we can say say
about the game because we don't know
much about it except for the main
character
the tone and the location
it's off to midnight I think I think
compulsion is going to surprise people I
do I you know Tim Tim Burton yeah stop
motion that's what it's called it looked
great bro don't don't expect like a
like a AAA product from these uh from
the studio
yeah I I do think compulsion is one of
the people that is going to make a very
very well polished double a studio
uh nine lives that Attica have you heard
about the game yes but I cannot say what
I've heard about this game
um I I think I think you guys are going
to be
very well Pleasant what what actually
comes out for this is it gonna be like
the most amazing thing since sliced
bread no but I think it's going to be
definitely one of those games that pops
in Game Pass and you have a good couple
like a week week and a half of fun and
then you move on to whatever's next and
I think that's the whole way that
they're doing what they're doing with
with Game Pass in general they want to
give you a certain amount of experience
and then have you move on to the next
game that's in in line
and that's why they give you a bunch of
variety of games and they do whatever
they can to keep you in game pass
because they want to keep you playing
more and more games
you know I love that though um every
game doesn't have to be a huge Triple A
uh big budget game I'm gonna tell you
how far for us is one of my most
favorite games of the year so far Dope
Game if if if if if if Xbox is able to
have AAA game
boom drop of high quality double a game
I'm all there for it man you know a good
game is a good game
so but South to midnight looks great to
me
like I said we don't know much about it
like we know it's a third person action
adventure game
and I'm curious to see what compulsion
can do because we happy few that game
had a lot of potential it wasn't great
but had a lot of potential contrast was
okay
um but this is going to be a game what
she's what stickers
but this is going to be a game that uh
you know they're going to be able to
make under Microsoft with Microsoft
resources so I'm expecting it to be
pretty good
what's that sticker bro
I don't know what the sticker is it's a
little it's a little princess oh where
it's a little princess
oh I'm sorry south of midnight I'm sorry
Joey south of midnight sorry uh fellas
in the chat let me let me change that
south of midnight I think South to
Midnight's gonna be a fun game I think
you guys gonna enjoy it but I I
definitely want to make sure that my
audience the 461 people in here watching
right now no
that this isn't a AAA product don't
expect some giant budgeted game for this
hey man what you think in 2024 though
yes beginning of 2025
model to end of 2024.
yeah I think it looks good I think that
game is going to be pretty good though
all right so let's
let's go to the Indie Games you know we
there is actually a decent amount of
indie games that was here today
and I I wanna I wanna get your opinion
on the indie games they say no shame
addict being a princess yeah you can't
shame me for being a princess that's
fine all right so uh I I want to hear
your opinion on some of the games
there's that 33 game that was there bro
I could 33 Co-op that is crazy dude I
have a hard time getting six people to
play Destiny with me I can't imagine 33
people yeah it looks pretty good though
man um
I saw that and I said at first it looked
like Hades because they look like Hades
but then oh man 33 player co-op that's
fire that's fire so yeah I thought it
was good man this game I definitely
going to give a try
yeah so I I think I think it's good man
I think that that's definitely one of
those that uh one of those
type of Indies that is really good on on
Game Pass like really good in Game Pass
absolutely I think it's especially you
could play 33 people like that's gonna
be like the easiest thing be like dude
just just get just get get game pass get
Game Pass like yeah it looked like there
was raids like maybe Destiny type of
raids in the game like like I'm hyped
for that man I'm I'm so hyped I think I
might hit them up and be like I I want
to do an interview with you guys because
I I feel like that game is going to do
well in Game Pass and I I'm excited what
else did you see that wasn't like
that wasn't Xbox Studios that you want
to talk about I saw the Leica Dragon
wealth game that's the sequel to like a
dragon and right that looked good
would you like the last last like a
dragon yeah because you like the turn
base the turn based one yeah I'd beat it
yeah oh okay so you okay so you're
looking forward to this next one then
yeah you know what that's crazy
um
I know I know that Persona leaked and
all of that stuff but
imagine if that wouldn't have got leaked
oh man but just think about this
Addicted Games three different Atlas
games were shown off on Xbox stage one
of them was was like a new game right
yeah brand new thing
yeah showing off my Xbox stage brand new
uh was it like a dragon game showing off
on Xbox stage
bro nobody would have thought this in
the Xbox one generation it's like
Japanese companies didn't mess with Xbox
at all and for Phil Spencer to you know
like remember Phil Spencer was going to
Japan and people's like man if you're
going to Japan and he ain't doing the
damn thing
it was over there making moves man it
took a while to to come to fruition but
here we are I can't believe you know a
Persona games three different Persona
games
uh what Atlas games were announced on
Xbox stage I will handle this super chat
after we finish talking about uh persona
persona looks good man Persona I think
it was Persona 3 Rebrand or whatever
it's called then we got Persona yeah
reloaded then we got Persona the taxes
game which I'm probably gonna play that
Persona 5 tactics and then we got the
Persona like the new game it's not
persona it's it's called metaphor
and it looks good and what I want to
like point out is the fact that we are
able it's a miracle that Microsoft was
able to get this on their stage like at
all
right yeah and it's I'm really excited
to see it please stop with the cat Okay
people are in the chat saying who's
torturing cats in the background Don't
make me say you're torturing cats it's
on your phone but it'll make me say
you're the one doing it
man why are you attacking me like that
because the chat is attacking me for you
attacking me
hey man there's a reality show baby
so yeah I think I think persona
yeah what I like is just the Japanese
support in general man yeah you know I
know you're a big a big fan of those
games yeah you know especially if we get
Persona 6 to be announced at a show yeah
you know I I she wasn't attacking cats
or anything she if we have a cat that
was in the the bat in the kitchen and
she played cats meowing to get that
cat's attention I don't want people
thinking there's some some cat abuse
going on in this house
I get it you don't need
okay we good
they know you ain't abusing cats we good
so
that's just the biggest thing like we
need more
more support on the Japanese Styles and
you know seeing seeing Sega and Atlas
and Yakuza in general you know seeing
Sega huge if you really think Sega was a
huge part of the show Absolutely they
announced three uh three Atlas gains of
one uh one Yakuza game like they were
huge in the show
so that's where I'm with you with this
yeah they need to buy them suckers and
buy them buy safe man yeah because
because you know what we saw what
happened with Square Enix they were all
buddy buddy and then before you know you
turn around
and now Square Enix is nowhere to be
seen on the Xbox platform you need to go
out there and back that truck up and
take that company you know go talk to
Sammy I'm pretty sure they sell you the
company
uh not just Sega bro
Capcom they announced a brand new IP on
Xbox stage man
yeah I can't think of the name of that
game for nothing it's better for it
no no no no Capcom oh Capcom I said
Capcom they announced a brand new IP on
Xbox stage
um that's pretty dope bro
I think
this was a really good show in terms of
Japanese
role-playing games I think they did a
really good job path of the Goddess
that's what it is so awesome thank you
yeah so five dollar super traffic from
El Nina attic when we talking about that
Final Fantasy 16 demo straight fire you
don't want me you don't want me to talk
about Final Fantasy 16 because I have a
feeling when I play that Oh Nana you
you're gonna really hate me okay because
because I am not kind to Final Fantasy
like you guys are I don't ignore all its
flaws because I was there
when we were in the golden edge of Final
Fantasy okay I have been feeling like
I've been in a reign of Final Fantasy
for like the past five ten years and it
doesn't seem to get better it seems to
get worse
then we gotta find out I've heard the
people say it was good though it's good
yeah I'm sure anything Final Fantasy
some of these people is great you know
they it it's mainly because I'm just
salty that they went away from turn Pace
that's pretty much what it is on my end
yeah two awesome Jennifer uh Nathaniel
mcstickins hey dirt I abuse cats all the
time Cricket oh my God
I don't think right I don't think you
understood
oh man she just got it she just got it
oh my God man my [__] crazy man
all right so you know what you know what
we'll do I'll talk about Final Fantasy
16 next week play that demo dirt
oh God yeah I I need to cut on my PS5 or
something yeah we might send my class
you say yours PlayStation 5 is literally
in my closet
I never use it I never use it I think
the controllers are all dead because
they only charge for like 20 minutes
damn uh so you know I I'll play that and
we will talk about that next week but
don't come in this chat
if you want if you don't want to get
your feelings hurt when it comes to that
demo because I I where does that game
come out
sometime this month doesn't it yeah like
probably I would say the 20th or the
23rd yeah something is yeah yeah next
week comes out next week
yeah so I will I'll I'll download it
yeah we'll play it and give uh we'll
we'll report back on that all right so
let's
let's go to the the meat and potatoes
man yeah star Phil
the game
that
completely
had PlayStation Fanboys have a meltdown
the game that's single-handedly made
them forget they had they just recently
had got a war
anything
they just recently had God of War they
just had um
they're about to have Final Fantasy 16.
they just they're about to get
Spider-Man made them forget all about
those experiences and only talk about
Starfield all week so tell me what your
feelings were about Starfield
attic
I thought it looked incredible
thought it looked incredible it lives in
the places the Fanboys you you know what
looks incredible when the PlayStation
Fanboys we have a meltdowns about it
that's all guys the video said the game
looks terrible they quit their live
stream
the game is dog [__] uh yeah El Nini 30
FPS yeah man um it's 30 FPS that's their
decision
that's Todd Howard's decision it is what
it is
um
you know so yeah
I don't know what to tell you I mean
y'all are using it you know bragging
about it but go ahead brag about it it's
not Howard's decision well I mean uh
Zelda was just 30 frames well here's the
thing I get it to the different
circumstances and Zelda can't
technically run at 60 but that's but
the Xbox series X clearly can't run at
60 with all they want to do either so
it's like just because and they act like
Zelda
and Starfield are on the same level as
terms of like scale no like clearly it
takes a lot more to run starfin and I do
think there's a way that they can make
star for run 34 60 frames I don't know
what kind of compromise they would have
to make and clearly Todd Howard ain't
trying to make those compromises he said
graphical graphical Fidelity would be
accomplished but to me you let your
consumer pick that if they want to take
a hit in that and make the game look
fuzzy or anything you let them make that
decision you don't make that decision
for them
fair enough but I mean
I mean but they're the developers is
their decision though right bro I mean
I feel you but they are trying to sell a
product to us as well
it's just like I I think it should be
one of those things where you have the
ability to play this game at either uh
4K or like even if it's like 1080P or
800 p60 like because when you click that
performance what you are choosing to put
it that low Todd isn't
I thought it was going to have a
performance mode I really did but you
know it is what it is
um
but a game looks great man I'm playing
on PC though by the way yeah PC all the
way I'm not playing that now
I'll probably have a review code for
that game so I'll probably play on both
just to see if like my I'm more keen and
I care more about field of views and
frames
because I feel like if they won't let me
control my field of view it's worse to
me than if I don't have 60 frames I
prefer both but for some reason when I
had that field of view the game feels
better with that frames it's it's a it's
a hit out of the park but the field of
view is really important to me as well I
just I feel like I feel like Starfall
about to hit it out of the park man my
question to you my question to you Dirk
and this is going to be a serious
question
what are the odds of this game of the
year oh you know what I believe it will
be in the nominations um I'm not sure if
it will win game of you because I just
don't know you know like you just don't
know with Zelda and
what else would be in there I don't know
like maybe there are some games that
haven't come out yet to be in a running
for game of the year but I believe it
will be nominated man
100 percent
um let me get this super chat from game
shark what's up game shot how you doing
brother he said 30 FPS and still number
one on Steam
all right hashtag face all right let's
let's head to Paul because I I got some
PlayStation fans in there I got some
Xbox fans in there
what is Game of the Year
hold up hold up
it'll be so funny if Starfield Wins Game
of the Year you know what they're gonna
say that was an Xbox game anyway
they're they're what is Game of the Year
I love this pole
let me vote
look look guys it's just all jokes you
guys know I'll be joking around with
that stuff that's funny
not Spider-man is Spider-man I was just
joking with you guys if you guys think
Spider-Man's gonna take it because right
now I think we all agree currently until
we see Spider-Man
and Starfield
the the top one is Zelda Zelda's winning
at currently at this at this point yeah
yeah yeah absolutely I would not deny
that now the question is what other
games do you think could be nominated
though because right now I see Zelda and
Starfield Zelda Starfield Spider-Man
nominated I believe so yeah yeah I think
it was uh so they said six is gonna get
nominated
they give it they give to a smaller
title yeah they do yeah here's a
question
does Final Fantasy 16 hit that I know I
don't know maybe you will I don't know
for spoken I don't know
Hogwarts Diablo Diablo Diablo Diablo
yeah oh yeah absolutely Diablo yeah
Hogwarts maybe I don't think Resident
Evil is gonna get it
nah that's a remake it might I don't
know sometimes
Diablo is definitely number three so we
got four so far four
I do think Hogwarts so you say Hogwarts
are you and and
are you in hard Works in there because I
do think Hogwarts will be ah I feel like
Hogwarts drops so fast though
Okay so
okay hold up let me think Liza P maybe
because they do give it to him okay what
about high five Rush Maybe
that might be nominated
uh I got four man I can't we'll give it
to Hogwarts
okay
and when that game terrible
that's funny
all right so I I you cut my Super Chat
no I think he read your super chat I was
I was reading it I thought oh okay my
bad my bad number two dollar super shirt
from game shark 30 frames and still
number one on Steam hashtag face hashtag
DC Grace uh quit
oh
BC guy quit Rage Quit himself Jerry Cass
guy I don't know I don't know what that
was about man he was uh really hating on
Starfield really bad man then he raised
quit like like what does Starfield do to
you bro it was kind of confused a little
bit too much I'm gonna be here with you
I apologize for all the sound in the
background guys you guys know normally
everybody over there I I know I I can't
help people know I stream
everyone has decided to take this time
to speak
so now everyone's quiet for like a whole
five seconds till they start talking
here see I told you already get oh [__]
so I think
I'm gonna be real with you dirt I'm
gonna be a hundred percent with you okay
Starfield taking game oh I hope so bro
Starfield taking game it looks good man
there's a buzz there's Buzz surrounding
this game
I don't know the last Xbox game
exclusive that got this much Buzz
surrounding it bro five dollar Super
Chat from Cowboys uh PS5 boys compared
uh Starfield to Spider-Man it's comical
nobody's considering Spider-Man as a
game of the generation Contender they
down bad
then we got a five dollar Super Chat
from Mandingo mcdickins DC guy doing all
that crying that's why his face is a 50
face per second DC guy face look like a
high school self
oh my God man come on guys don't bring
that on our Lord's Channel man come on
bro yo these people be Savage
Space Marine two look good that's not a
game of the year Concentra I'm sorry
about that space Marine too I didn't
even see that so imagine
game of the year
they they're doing
they're doing Game of the Year
what's crazy if Microsoft
gets to be able to buy
blizzard
Diablo and starfield's gonna be
uh man now if that happens they won't
give Diablo to Xbox give them no credit
but Starfield Man Xbox has been helping
Horizon came out this year didn't it
DLC oh okay so yeah it came out last
year
so it's gonna be crazy because you're
gonna have you're gonna have Starfield
Spider-Man 2 and Zelda most likely going
to be the real Three contenders maybe
Diablo Diablo has been hitting pretty
hard and they yeah this is gonna be the
first year where the Xbox people can
pull up to the game awards
we outside
[Music]
yo you're gonna have way more Xbox
people streaming that [__] this year
I have nothing in the race man
that's another narrative that's dead
if XBox if Xbox game wins game that's
another narrative that's dead
because they say no we're for no games
to y'all don't have any game of the year
now I'm gonna need then you know what's
crazy if like hellblade or a valid wins
it next year
and then the year after that Fable wins
it
and the year after that the outer worlds
two wins it oh my God yo we potentially
at a place where Xbox can win game of
the year the next five years back to
back
there you go be back to back to back no
but that's fine I know we're just having
fun but at the end of the day man Xbox
is finally in the position daddy like
you're saying though they're gonna have
some good games every year bro
that was some dry years for us but
they're we're in the position Xbox is in
a position where they're going to have
some games every year some some good
games every year Game of the Year
contingency obviously I'm joking around
you know I do think Fable has a good
chance of being uh gave me the air I
don't know about like a vowed or
hellblade I have to see more on those
titles I have a lot of faith in about
Val could easily take game of the year
next year I just don't know what I don't
think Wolverine's coming out next year
so I I think I think that's a 2025 game
so so what is PlayStation gonna have
yeah games is the service
they're gonna have them back to back
five dollars to draft from El Nina Zelda
has a uh in a lot we all know starfish
is going to release like a buggy mess I
don't think that I don't I actually
think they go they go They're gonna hit
you man they gonna hit you with my booty
said what
he said uh if Starfield released today
it will have the least amount of bugs in
any but there's the game they said they
have
so many people testing this game bro
this one you know would be crazy I think
the game is done yeah if we see a
situation
where there is mad games coming out this
80 85 90 and above
um
that's the that's possible though
yeah I I I and imagine just imagine Chad
and I know it's very unlikely I know
it's unlikely you don't have to tell me
it's unlikely I know you're gonna say it
in the chat but you don't have to say it
this is the attic show where we do the
show in the added world and I'm the
mayor I'm the president
I dictate [__] here when I say ghosts
and it would be crazy if this year's
Starfield Wins Game of the Year next
year a valid Wins Game of the Year the
year after that Fable Wins Game of the
Year the after that avowed once game of
the year the act the year after that
Elder Scrolls six wins game oh man wow
that's unbelievable oh dude I still
think it will have some bugs but they're
saying it's not going to be as bad as it
usually is Yo imagine if that happened
we're gonna have to call some Wellness
checks on some of the PlayStation fans
hey hey
now corpse is talking trash
he said not factions factions ain't
gonna be nominated for nothing
oh man I'm sorry she's just gonna get
nominated for finally being out oh man
okay this is getting messy Ally This Is
The Alley show man you know we like we
don't get this messy over here do we add
it this is getting messy bro
we'll talk about this after this jeez
why is everyone to talk to me when I'm
doing the podcast
yeah we win it man we win all right so
let's what games was not at the Showcase
you know let's move on because uh we got
a little messy there it's fine though
27 minutes it looks like we might get
out of here on time man
let's go baby games not at the Showcase
obviously we saw a bunch of stuff but
there was a bunch of stuff not there
Indiana Jones people thought that was
going to be there we we didn't see
anything related to
Wolfenstein we didn't see State of Decay
there perfect art there out of worlds
two there uh obviously oh no no we gotta
talk about Clockwork Revolution I forgot
oh yeah we gotta talk about that bro we
gotta talk about that real quick I'm not
putting out the timestamps you timestamp
off you're gonna have to just deal with
that all right if you don't deal with
that I'm kicking you out of addicts
world all right so what was your
thoughts on Clockwork they didn't really
show us a lot but it showed me enough
where I got hype I don't know why
absolutely bro um first of all the first
thing you notice is kind of BioShock
Infinite Vibe that's the first thing you
notice and I love any type of time
manipulation game stuff seeing that
brick wall or whatever it was humble
that you were able to put it back looks
great man the character seemed
interesting the world
the world
has my interest bro and Exile doing this
Triple A
RPG I love it man and um
Brian was named Brian Fargo this guy
that he was about to kind of retire from
gaming onto Microsoft approached them
and he was like oh I can make a triple a
game with Microsoft resources
let's go
and uh yeah it's it's looking good man I
think that game is probably 20 25 also
it looks great though once if it's 20 26
if anyone game of the year
yeah man you don't even bring up that
game right
here you get a game of the year we all
get game of the year except for
PlayStation they don't get them
hey Adam me you was talking about CCI
trailers um showing you part of the game
what about that PlayStation game Concord
with jiggly hamburger what do you think
that game will be about not game of the
year I can tell you
[Music]
gonna be mad at you in the chat man
they're already mad at me but I said I'm
married what they gonna do you don't see
look besides Donald Trump generally our
presidents don't get indicted on
anything okay I think I'm fine in the
Attic world you can't you can't indict
me okay I Knight you I kick you out not
the other way around that's funny man
I got a lot of faith in them too
so I think it's going to be good man I
think that's cool we don't really know a
lot about that game but you know let's
let's move back on what's not there you
know what's funny
is I was joking around about the game of
the year stuff but once let's say those
games go through then you could have
Bethesda software Studios ready to go
again you're gonna have the Avail tea
ready to go again you're gonna have all
these Studios ready to go again and then
when those people are done the Fable
studios are going to be ready to go
again the perfect art studio is going to
be ready to go again you know what
PlayStation I think it's safe to suit
it's safe to say the you PlayStation
Fanboys are done you ain't winning the
game of the year until you until you
have kids until your kids have kids all
right it's officially a wrap King held
the line so hard it scared the the big
times out of the room shout out to King
man because when people was was what was
jumping ship people was leaving after
rainfall people were saying feel should
be fired
King Dave said we will hold the line
and people rallied around them now look
at it
look at it now beautiful they're like
we'll hold the line and then the LIE got
held not that hard let go let go
hey bro there's people making fun of the
king for saying that man people was
doing videos making fun of King for
saying hold the line now look at you now
yo what's funny
ABK do if that gets closed you
guaranteed Microsoft a good 90 plus
every year because for some reason
that's like there's a good 80 85 Plus
game that comes out of Call of Duty
every year yeah
we hope we held the line so hard they
packed up well
this this is crazy man shout out to King
man he always get love for me he put
himself out there with people was was
really down on Xbox man
I think it's a good time man you know
overall
overall expectations
you know when it comes to perfect art
that's not going to be there you know
clearly there Microsoft showed us more
stuff and I feel like they they showed
us enough on Starfield to get us really
hyped about it uh but we got to see more
on these other games you know
I want to see more when it comes to the
outer worlds too when it comes to State
of Decay too I want to see more when it
comes to the other things that Ninja
Theory is working on and I also just
want to see more on you know it comes to
Bethesda you know what's what's machine
games working on this Indiana Jones is
the only game they're working on because
it seems like every other studio is
having working on two or three games
what are these other Studios working on
and that's what I got to see you know I
joke around you know PlayStation's still
going to pull up
but the difference is is PlayStation
pulled up at Xbox sent like one dude and
he got destroyed now now it's
PlayStation gonna show up with that big
God of War dude talking like Arnold
Schwarzenegger and you're gonna have
Microsoft show off like eight people
that's small
remember in the rundown with the rock
they're like you can fight yeah they
little people
and they whipped them up yeah I remember
that movie
he's like he's like you can look up and
he's in the in the tree with the branch
now I remember that yeah it was whupping
them up but it's um listen well let me
say this right quick PlayStation um
they're going to be fine like we're just
having fun right now right we're just
having fun
um but this isn't the same PlayStation
that you guys are used to though it is
definitely not the same Xbox
no it's definitely not the same Xbox
that y'all made fun of so that's the
difference between the two
you have woken the Beast
and at this point the only people you
have yourself to blame is the
PlayStation Army you know if you guys
would have just kept your map shut and
you would have just if you would have
just agreed with the Xbox people you
know the Xbox people that PL that the
Xbox does nothing wrong in all those
years you would have disagreed with them
and said you know what Xbox people you
write Xbox killed it this year
you wouldn't have walked in the Beast we
would still have seven Studios right now
you would you would silently be winning
because they think they doing everything
right but you can you went out there and
you talked you made your posts you made
your pose you did your petitions and you
woke up a beast and that Beast
so happen to have a trillion dollar bank
account
where you go there you go and then all
those years how many times did you hear
dirt Xbox these days the richest company
in the world why aren't they spending
their money
and then what happens
Microsoft's like We Buy in these five
Studios they are okay you know I really
like Ninja Theory but you know it's not
too bad
okay you know I I just I like that but I
mean it is it is what it is they reached
out and grabbed excited that's not too
much I get it I can't think of Richard I
got Bethesda I feel like this is this is
a little too much
this is organic
even though Bethesda has had a serious
intimate relationship with Microsoft for
years then they reached out and grab
Activision this is
tell me tell me they don't buy them
[Music]
that will be man listen
I'ma say this
they asked for this what I'm saying they
asked for they said last generation like
you mentioned well Xbox are they gonna
even try to compete
this is Microsoft this is a trillion
dollar company why don't y'all act like
a trillion dollar company
they acting like one you know what's
funny
Microsoft is doing what they what
they're doing in the gaming this year
now what they've been doing in every
other industry it's just they didn't do
it in this industry and now that they've
started doing it in this industry oh my
God we don't we don't like this but but
Microsoft uh Sony can leverage their
Spider-Man IP and get a comic book
beloved franchise such as Spider-Man
exclusive to their platform that's
organic growth like
King is a legend man I love the Xbox
Community you don't see King on the PSI
you don't see a king on the PS side you
don't see Sony Executives participating
in the community because they don't have
a community for the most part all them
pictures that you guys took with Xbox
Executives bro I have never seen Jim
Ryan take a picture with one of these
ponies out out here in this community I
haven't even seen Sean Lane well maybe
Sean Lane took some uh Herman Holtz I
haven't seen him take any pictures with
anybody bro you took pictures with
everybody right
with everybody uh Sarah Bond
yeah well I didn't take a picture of
Sarah Paul but I get oh you didn't oh I
know it was like well what somebody else
did I saw her a lot like
all jokes aside this isn't that everyone
celebrate thing this is a Microsoft is
actually showing you what they're doing
obviously we got to see what Starfall
comes out and it is you know I do think
what they showed us is going to be a
representation of the actual game but we
need to see how all that connects and
makes a very fine-tuned game I agree
with you guys I think we need to see
that but at the same time we cannot not
give credit where credit is due
Microsoft has been throwing out this
money for the past few years and we're
starting to see some of the fruits of
that labor sure I think
until Starfield comes out we need to
hold the line more you know because when
Starfield comes out
and it's an if it's a 90 plus 30 if it's
a 90 Plus 30. it's over
there's no more hole in the line because
you guys were treated
and then if Fable comes out and it hits
we ain't holding the line no more dirt
because we at they front door they gonna
have to hold the line
right and you know what you know no
fence to the PlayStation Community you
know uh you guys you guys bicker at each
other too much there ain't no holding
line with you guys you know if we get
yeah if we get the war to your front
door
you just gotta let us in like
you can't stand this the the smoke you
can't stay in the heat
right and that we we and you know it's
like that thing in Marvel where it's
like we got an army we got a king
we we're gonna
have a video game where King is like the
Leonidas thing going off in The Lord of
the Rings going side to side like this
is where they die
we have fought them back to their front
doors there you go that's crazy we held
the lie that we proceeded to go forward
this is a fun show I love a fun show
let me make sure I get all these super
chats real quick before we take off you
know they actually got a space now for
just super chats
it's called fun it's called fan funding
like if you click where you like go from
a live chat to a top chat it literally
will tell you where all the super chats
are in a row
oh really oh on the PC though you gotta
be on your PC all right okay so first
off I want to take everyone through we
had up to like almost 520 people and you
hit that like button on your way out all
this is jokes guys don't take none of
this seriously you know part part of the
reasons part of the reason it's so easy
to agitate some of you PlayStation fans
is because you take this stuff too
seriously and there is people on the
Xbox side that takes it too seriously
but we're not one of them so you can't
agitate us now sure you guys might have
triggered me a little bit over the Fable
so that's fine I could take that smoke
because I because it's like it's like
I'm a Super Saiyan man you might beat me
up a little I'ma come back at you twice
as hard
so I appreciate everyone coming through
here definitely hit that like button you
guys way out dirt tell the people what
you're doing
let me uh check out my channel man
um you know I I've been crying about my
chapters lately because YouTube took my
chapters for some reason like always the
timestamps still work but they took my
chapters I'm trying to figure out why I
hit him up they said oh you don't really
know why
I don't have any strikes but I think um
you know uh my channel you know I need
to clean up a little bit it's only my
podcast you know like you know like
especially the chat you know like
Mandingo me think it's ah no I'm choking
that's the homie but somebody you know
we we get a little crazy over there so I
that's the only thing I could think why
they took my chapters maybe it's a
glitch but I've been crying about people
say shut up they're cried about your
chapters but it actually affects
um the the the channel I don't get Like
My Views are okay
but it does affect all of that view Subs
so I'm growing a little bit slower right
like for the last month I am still
growing though but yeah I'm trying to
get my chaps back man and don't be
talking trash they don't stop crying
because I am crying but uh check out my
channel guys
with Xbox maybe you can argue dirt
you're not crying enough
that [__] up that'll take you seriously
yeah but put that in the chat man put
that in the chat yeah
I'm about to hit uh put my channel in
the chat thank you guys for rocking out
with me
you guys awesome let me
do you know I can't I'm I'm on my phone
I can't do it as fast so
thank you bro go there follow dirt man
he's a nice Xbox Channel that's that is
free of harm you guys there will be no
harm done to you you know you got our
PlayStation people in there they they
trying to you guys gotta hold the line
here over there
you and the see this is the front line
iops in the front line you gotta hold
the line to be here dirt's like the
archers in the back that don't get hit
like
yeah that's telling the people to shoot
the arrows over us yeah as soon as we
see an enemy up there's a pop and the
arrow but uh yeah we have a lot of fun
over there though man but uh man I had
Rand on the show this past monday it was
a great show was a lot of fun man and um
yeah guys stop by you know have some fun
yeah I appreciate everybody uh you know
shout out to oral wolf it's James uh she
in the chat she put the sticker on my
chest
uh shame on her yeah
I appreciate every couple we're gonna
send you guys to fame entertainment he's
doing the podcast right now with Level
One gaming go in there tell them the
attic show sent you I'm in look at two I
want to see the attic show in that chat
because I want these people to know that
I was there when no one else was it nah
I'm joking I'm joking see if we got to
show the other Xbox people we holding
the line because when when we all come
together we make a big ass line that's
when we start attacking people so go
over there and show him we holding the
line I don't wanna hear no excuses okay
go over there and hold the damn line or
I'mma tell Cog and I'm gonna tell King
and we coming after you we gonna take
you out of the line because you didn't
hold the line I'm joking with you guys I
appreciate everyone coming through we
out of here peace